you moved here I did yeah you moved here
since we last talked to you yeah you
made a big move so like um cuz you moved
from New York yeah wow and was there
part of you that was kind of scared was
there like what were you thinking cuz I
mean I've thought about it you know and
and a lot of people have done it you
know no I'd come down here a lot because
you know do Rogan's podcast do podcast
down here do comedy so I've been down
here enough so I wasn't worried about
like living here I was worried
about uh comics being like ah [__] he
left New York he's trying to [__]
suck Rogan's dick that that was like I
was like that's going to happen I know
that M uh no I was excited Matt was
excited about it so I knew I had Matt
coming down with me and then we brought
our other friends and was good yeah yeah
yeah I uh and ta taxes are oh yeah butt
[__] New York dude yeah it's crazy it's
great yeah and uh oh what's that in your
daughter's bedroom what's that in the oh
that's extra taxes that's what ta dude
that's taxes and a couple of SAS bro
like damn lot of taxes up there oh it's
crazy it's extra I think 14% what's the
state tax rate in New York City up there
Zachary I think it's uh 10 oh he's
guessing what is it no I'm not guessing
I got
here 4% to 10.9% you see here wow cuz
Los Angeles is 13 I think per yeah I was
Hing around that 4% range for a while
when I lived in New York and then you
probably moved up into at least that
6.85% yes yeah yeah dude so that's kind
of crazy so you moved yeah like yeah I
think some people say that they're like
oh do you want to move there because
Rogan's there because Dylan's there it
seems like the new thing and I think
yeah I kind of maybe I don't know if I
had some fear I don't know I don't know
if I had fear of that you definitely
think oh people think you're just yeah
you're just riding that guy's wiener you
know yeah somebody F yeah I mean um but
also he's like I would say it if I was
still in New York somebody else moved
here be like [__] [__] couldn't take
it I'd do the same thing so yeah come
back and pay these high taxes pay these
[__] taxes live in a [__] hole in New
York
yeah um but no I just wanted to move to
a place where you could do standup
during the week and forever it was just
New York and La that's now now you can
do it in Nashville and Austin does it
feel well Nashville you cannot oh really
yeah you cannot it's not the same I will
I'll say that 100% it is not the same as
what it feels like here yeah like even
just going over to um the Mother Ship
it's like you can do three sets in a
night probably yeah you can do you can
do four every single time there's
usually two shows in the small room two
in the wow main room I mean that's crazy
you do four sets a night yeah four sets
a night in the same building that you
can go do I mean that's that's
unprecedented you know it's changing
what's nice is watching like like
mccusker cuz he was in Philly where you
can't do that and now he's been living
here just a few few months and he's he's
got he's gotten so good really just from
doing yeah he can do it every night yeah
I met him last night or I met him uh at
your yeah I met him at your podcast I
met his wife too yeah Britney is her
name yeah yeah yeah yeah she got he got
a beautiful little wife yeah she's great
um yeah dude I think having that much
ability to get up is it starts to change
you you're like oh I just practiced it
he didn't go in there let me let me try
it you're like right there you get the
bomb four times yeah take it on the road
be like I'm not going to change anything
[__] it's still not
working what has been like did you find
a house immediately how did you find a
house down here uh I just had a lady a
real estate lady I was like I just need
a house that's furnished because I don't
have anything yeah so she first house
she picked out I was like that's it oh
yeah and I didn't see it until I moved
in nuh-uh it was nice yeah I moved in I
was like it's [__] nice oh it's like
that show where you meet your wife the
first time yeah that's Brave I was the
thing I was most worried about was the
television mhm cuz I thought it was like
they I thought they were going to hit me
with like the Airbnb pictures like you
get there and you're like oh [__] this
house sucks TV's big right so I'm good
oh that's good H we're set thank God
it's furnisher I would have never I'd
never furnish it really yeah I'd have
one folding chair in front of the TV
yeah yeah yeah my house was furnished
when I got my house thank God and uh and
then who told me oh Tom sigur told me in
this room he said hey man you got to
start getting some art for yourself you
have to get something you like cuz it
really does start to change the way that
you think about your own home Tom's
becoming like the Jay-Z of standup you
got to invest in art you got do yeah
he's got art he's got sneakers he's got
uh yamar uh what the car is called the
fastest one McLaren McLaren is that
it yeah that's wild to me I think I
would be scared to be like real R I
wouldn't know how to do it I bet you're
all right oh I think I'm I'm okay having
more money for sure but I think if I
tried to be real Rich I just don't know
how I would I don't know what I would
spend money on you
know like would you get a super fast car
um no I don't I'm afraid to drive fast
yeah yeah I think yeah I just don't know
what I would get probably guns probably
a couple you got to get guns Yeah couple
for your neighbors couple for you give
them out yeah you don't want to shoot at
your neighbors hide them in your kids
room your neighbor kids room start
[__] guns how's it have you felt good
about moving here now once you moved
here was it kind of like different or
was it different than you thought like
what are some things that were kind of
cool about it I don't know it's I you
know you know when you move I was sad
for like a week oh really yeah I was by
myself it was scary I was used to having
[__] I was used to living in
apartments I lived in Philly and New
York the last decade so I was like
there's usually somebody around now I
was out there by myself I got scared for
a while I was scared really I get scared
at night noises yeah yeah you think it's
a noise and he say you farted just
waking myself up with
farts the [__] was
that uh yeah I mean I was scared for a
while yeah I would I was emotional I
would cry during movies when I was at at
night by myself oh yeah yeah uh so
that's what you have to look forward to
scare and you cry that's it oh that's
just I think that's just part of the
American condition these days then oh
you're fine then yeah that was all um
yeah cuz I think I thought I don't know
if I thought Nashville would be a busier
comedy scene I I I didn't think that um
because they just have one club that's
like a functioning Club there right it's
like they have a a headliner flies in
every weekend so they they help you as
much as they can but they just don't
have as much space you know um and then
there's not a lot as many other rooms
around the area but here it's like yeah
it feels like you could go like we met a
guy last night he done like five spots
you know yeah you can do that here it's
like wow yeah I mean that's crazy to
think you could do that in a city Ian
there was never ever maybe Chicago you
could do that in maybe I don't know New
York obviously you can yeah la la
definitely those are the two yeah but
that was yeah I don't know do you think
about moving back from here you think
you're settled in you're good I don't
know I don't think I'll live here
forever but yeah I like it here yeah
what that's just a big I don't yeah I I
don't know I'll probably move home to
like outside of Philly wow yeah
eventually yeah yeah I like it there I
don't know sometimes I think about maybe
moving or getting a also living
somewhere else I think it's fun to spend
time down here Austin is cool a is fun
you can do standup it's a beautiful city
yeah a nice city it's a fun city yeah
there's a lot of neat stuff yeah there's
a lot of neat stuff I think so that's
been pretty cool just thinking about it
you know even coming to seeing like your
house it's like oh okay this is what it
would be like to live here this seems
like I could do this you
[Music]
know